من جديد نعود الى الاخبار العاجله التي
ننقلها اليكم وهذه الصور التي تشاهدونها
الان وصلتنا مثل ما ذكرنا انفا قبل قليل
والتي تظهر اذا اعتراض صواريخ القبه
الحديديه على ما يبدو لرشق صاروخيه وصفت
بالكذبه استهدفت 19 بلده بغلاف غزه وفي
النقب الغربي كما اكد مراسل الجزيره نقلا
عن مصدره اسرائيليه التي اكدت بان هذا قصف
من شمال القطاع تحديدا استهدف عددا من
البلدات بغلاف غزه في النقب الغربي ايضا
وتشير الاعداد بان هناك 19 بلده
مستهدفه اذا هذه الصور نتابعها الان سنقدم
لكم بالتاكيد ما يريدنا من صور خلال هذه
التغطيه المستمره هذا
اي مشهد اخر هذه الزاويه ثانيه تظهر اذا
ما يبدو انه اعتراض الصواريخ القبه
الحديديه
لمجموعه وصفت بالكبيره من الصواريخ هي
رشقه صاروخيه اطلقت من شمالي القطاع
باتجاه 19 بلده بغلاف غزه وفي النقب
الغربي بالفعل هذه الرشقات
الصاروخيه مثل ما تعرفون هي مستمره منذ
فتره منذ اسابع من اكتوبر الكثير منها بات
ينطلق من جديد